-You look fantastic.
-I do.
-I love this, I love the jacket.
[ Laughter ]
You really do.
You know, I haven't seen you --
-You accept compliments
in America -- yes.
-Oh, you just agree to it.
-You agree.
-You go, "Yeah."
How's our pal Rita Ora?
How's Rita doing?
-She's good.
-She's no longer my pal.
She's my wife now.
-[ Laughing ] Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I didn't get the invitation.
I didn't get the invitation
'cause I didn't know.
-No one did.
No one was invited.
-Yeah.
-No, no.
-She's one of my favorites.
And you two together
are just unbelievable.
-Yeah.
-I know that she surprised you
with this trip to Scotland.
-Yeah, it wasn't one of those --
a surprise, "Hey!"
an all, massive, big,
giant extravaganza in Scotland.
It was really just her
wanting to go to this
one specific place.
So Airbnb have these, like,
pop-up experiences you can do,
and they did the Barbie house,
obviously, for the movie.
But Rita found an article online
where they'd re-created
a replica of Shrek's house.
-Uh-huh, yeah, yeah.
-In Scotland.
And it was just --
And it was open
to anyone to go and stay.
And she said, "I think
we're gonna go do that,"
and made me go to Scotland
just to stay it's Shrek's house.
-Yeah.
So she showed you this on...?
-Yeah, and I said, "Ha ha.
That's funny,"
and she said,
"I'll tell you what's funny.
We're going."
[ Laughter ]
And then dragged me to --
Didn't drag me.
I was into it.
Took me to Scotland.
And then we got there,
and you had to drive
like 40 minutes off
the main road, over dirt roads,
and it's, like,
in the middle of nowhere.
It felt like a trick.
Felt like,
"Did I do something wrong?
Is this the last time
I'm going to see anyone?"
-Life.
-The last -- is this it?
-The sunshine.
Yeah, this is over.
Yeah, of course.
-And then we got out there,
and it's beautiful.
Like, just so much effort,
and right down
to the finest detail.
Inside was -- looked
exactly like in the movie.
Then she says, "Put that on,"
and made me dress up as Shrek.
[ Laughter ]
And she pulled out --
And everyone -- there's
some, like, videos and photos,
and everyone thinks we took
a camera crew with us.
It was just us two, and she put
green paint all over herself.
-Now, do you --
Am I missing something?
Do you like Shrek?
-Not that much. I mean...
-Yeah, okay.
Does she like Shrek that much?
Just out of...
-Clearly.
-Yeah.
-I didn't know about that.
I didn't know about
this infatuation.
-Well, here's -- here's --
here's Rita as Fiona.
But I want to show you.
[ Laughter ]
Let me zoom in.
Here's you as Shrek.
-There's me.
[ Laughs ]
Look at that.
-It's unbelievable.
-Look at that mask.
-Unbelievable.
You know, I know you as a --
as a fun human being.
You're always nice to me.
But you're very talented,
and I respect your work.
-That's also true.
-Yeah.
-And, also --
but I love your fashion.
And I think you're a
good-looking dude
and a stylish dude.
And I go, "Well, here we go."
I get this thing to go --
did you see? --
the Hermès fashion show?
-Yeah.
I don't know.
Just the things I do
when I get bored is walk
for Hermès
in New York Fashion Week.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know
how I got in that door.
-They go, "Have you seen Taika?
Have you seen Taika's,
what he's doing?"
And I go, "What?"
So they -- Hermès had you
walking the runway
in their fashion --
at New York Fashion Week.
For real.
-It's been quite the year, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at you.
Now, see...
Is that face...
-Are you upset?
-...too intense?
-Yeah.
You got really --
-Is it selling the jackets,
or is it just saying,
"Get out of my way"?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, it's -- it's not --
-It's not that.
-It's not this guy.
I mean...
[ Laughter ]
-That's the same guy.
-It's the same coat.
-Same person.
-It's the same outfit.
-Same outfit.
-It's the same coat.
[ Laughter ]
It's the same coat, but it's
just worn different ways.
-It's just attitude.
That's why I wear Hermès.
-It's attitude.
-This is actually the same suit.
[ Laughter ]
-We split it up.
-My attitude's different.
-Yeah. Your attitude changes
a little bit, yeah.
-It really looks like this.
-Yeah. I think you have
a very positive attitude.
-I think I'm probably a very --
I'm probably the perfect model
'cause the only thing
I cared about was
if the clothes looked good.
And if that small
little company,
Hermès, would sell
some of these jackets.
[ Laughter ]
-Small little company.
Yeah.
Can we talk about your film,
"Next Goal Wins"?
-Yes, please.
-This is --
It's in theaters this Friday.
"Next Goal Wins."
It's based on a true story.
How'd you hear about the story?
-So, a few years ago,
there was a documentary made.
And it's a true story of the
worst soccer team in the world.
So --
And that's American Samoa.
They're no longer the worst.
It's not really a spoiler,
but --
But back then --
In the history of the country,
they'd never won a game
or scored a goal.
And they still hold the record
for the biggest
international loss,
and that's against Australia,
and they lost 31-0.
-Oh, stop.
-Yeah.
-Can't they call it
after a certain amount of goals?
-You can't -- I don't know.
They're throwing all the towels
onto the field.
So, no, they -- and after that,
you'd think they would --
that would deter most people
from playing again,
but they had the tenacity and
the determination to get better.
And they got a coach in, who's
played by Michael Fassbender,
and he turns the team around.
And he's a bit of a lost soul,
as well,
so they turn him around,
and they --
and together they kind of
create, like a really nice,
sort of happy family together,
and they go on to --
to play a game...
-Yeah.
-...of soccer.
-Yeah. Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're not giving any spoilers.
-Not giving anything.
-No! Don't give anything away.
It's a great film.
-Here's a great idea.
Make a film
about the worst soccer team
in the world who get even worse
by the end.
-Yeah, they lose.
-Everyone wants to see that.
-Yeah, they lose at the end.
Yeah.
The whole cast is great, though.
Mike Fassbender is great.
Everybody in the film is great.
And there's this kid.
Can you tell me about Armani?
-Oh, yeah.
There's a kid
in the film called Armani.
So when I approached this film,
I just wanted to be very open
and fluid to this,
the creative process.
You know, any idea's
worth trying.
And not to be so rigid
in my in my approach.
And as a result,
I was sort of just open
to whatever was going on.
And Michael came over
after about a week and a half
of shooting, and he said,
"Man, I've just met this --
some 10- or 11-year-old kid
over by the unit table,
and I don't know who he is
or where he comes from,
but he's fascinating.
I wish he was in the movie."
And I said, "Well, let's just
put him in the movie."
And so that kid just kept --
we just told the kid
to keep turning up every day,
and he came in,
and he's a really big part
of the movie now.
[ Laughter ]
-That's just great.
-And he's like,
you keep showing up...
-Just go show -- go and be --
and go hang around movie sets.
That's what everyone wants.
Really good advice --
go hang around movie sets.
-Yeah, but that's the vibe.
You put love into the movie,
and you get love
out of the movie.
-That's exactly right.
-What I'm talking about, buddy.
I want to show a clip.
Here's a look
at "Next Goal Wins."
Take a look at this.
-Mr. Rongen, I thought you
depend on us.
-Ace, I'd like to apologize.
-Oh.
-But I won't.
-As a rule, I don't apologize.
I'm not apologizing
for that, either.
Look, I know you don't like me.
I don't like me.
But we need to work together.
This player interchangeable
with this player.
Switch it 'round.
Works this way, too.
Wax on, wax off.
We've also got the three pigs.
The wolf is coming
all the way back here.
He's going to blow
your house down.
This is where we want to go.
All roads lead to Rome.
What is this [bleep]
A Sharpie.
Get me another board.
[ Men exclaim ]
Ice is your friend.
It'll help those muscles.
Got you in the nads there.
Way off.
Miss.
Finds it!
Whoo!
-Come on! That's
Taika Waititi right there.
"Next Goal Wins."
Uh, before you go, I thought --
I thought maybe we could play a
game inspired by your new movie,
"Next Goal Wins."
What do you think of this?
-I think that's a great idea.
-Let's do it. Here we go.
-I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Next Goal Wins ♪
♪ Next Goal, Next Goal Wins ♪
♪ Next Goal Wins ♪
-Now, "Next Goal Wins"
is about soccer.
In America, we don't really know
soccer that well,
but we're getting to learn.
-But here's what we do know
in America.
-Baseball.
Yeah, we know baseball.
But here's what I have.
I have soccer balls,
I have baseball bats,
and a basketball hoop.
We're gonna bat the soccer balls
into the hoop.
Whoever gets a basket
first wins.
Get it?
Next goal --
-Next basket goal wins.
-Well, that's a sequel.
Yeah, all right, here we go.
All right.
Let's go.
-Let's do it.
-Good luck.
-Okay. You ready?
-Ready, and go, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yes!
Ah.
♪♪
-Are you coming close?
[ Audience exclaims ]
Are you getting even close?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
This guy can do anything.
This guy can do anything!
Taika Waititi!
His movie, "Next Goal Wins,"
is in theaters
everywhere this Friday.
Rachel Zegler joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.